[Music]
no it must be an anomaly site again I
already have ten times mother normally
this sample must contain a new element a
radioactive element it would have to be
100 no thousands of times stronger than
uranium we must isolate it
well then I suppose we're going to need
our own laboratory
do you remember the cootie spirit and
other activities working tirelessly side
by side without heat in a lab or funding
for the research its Olympic wealth
security spent four years on that paper
I've got three hours so the Patent
Office opens you should get some rest
you can't think probably without sleep
don't need sleep I need more coffee a
lot of it do you remember our thought
experiments on gas degree at university
those weeks we spent holed up in my room
I don't know required a lot of
experimentation yes not all of it to do
it science what is going about it all
wrong
what if instead of fighting gases which
having a cup of coffee you really must
sweep up yacouba's van't hoff snow by
the paper from 1901 particles in a
solution behaved like a gas when sugar
dissolves in coffee water surrounds
glucose and tears it from a sugar
crystal correct the more sugar I add the
thicker the coffee becomes if we can
calculate the osmotic pressure perhaps
we can deduce the precise number no one
to prove the existence as module 2n
dishes No
[Music]
you